[Music]
ukraine's military has posted videos of
its soldiers launching strikes using u.s
delivered weapons called highmars these
long-range rocket launchers that can
fire up to 53 miles are being used by
kiev to blast russian ammunition stores
and hamper crucial supply lines like
this bridge to the occupied city of
hassan
military analysts say recent attacks
with the systems could be slowing down
moscow's advances in eastern ukraine
the highmars
could very well enable the ukrainians to
push back against the russians in a very
significant way but to turn the tide of
the war and reclaim control of some
russian-occupied territories keefe says
it needs more long-range and
sophisticated weapons
as the u.s prepares to send another 1
billion dollars in military aid here's
how haimars are helping ukraine and
which other american weapons could
enhance kev's capabilities
since the start of the war in late
february the biden administration has
provided a range of weapons to ukraine
those include harpoon anti-ship missiles
and artillery units such as the m777
howitzers but military analysts say the
delivery of highmars in late june has
been a game changer
that's because of the advanced
capabilities of the weapons highmars
have roughly double the range of the
previously provided howitzers and
defense experts say they have greater
precision and higher mobility than
russia's equivalent the bm30 smirch
which has a longer range they're also
very
easy to
to move and operate so
the operators now are sitting in these
high mars they're they're sort of
they're comfortable they're safe they
feel protected
and the technology is quite
sophisticated so they're they really
feel empowered
operators need around five minutes to
set up the weapons to strike targets but
only need around 20 seconds to be able
to relocate after they have fired and
that's really important because
the risk with artillery is the
the possibility of counter-attack um by
the russians that they identify where
this fire is coming from and they
respond
they are all reasons why hymers are
strengthening keys forces at a critical
moment in the war for weeks moscow has
been bombarding eastern ukraine with
artillery heavy strikes culminating in
moscow claiming control over the luhansk
region in early july
but the us rockets are now enabling
ukraine's forces to strike russian bases
these satellite images show an
ammunition storage unit on july 11th and
a day later after kiev said it was
leveled by highmars so they've been
going off to russian supply depots
exactly and sort of limiting the base at
which the russians can resupply their
frontline that's siddharth cashel a
military analyst at the royal united
services institute he says haimars are
forcing russia to make adjustments on
the battlefield so the russians have
adapted by doing things like moving
supply depots outside the effective
range of hymas but what that means is
now supply lines are even longer which
means that the time and logistical
effort of moving supplies to the front
line is it's great
as well as moving some of its equipment
further away from combat russia has made
targeting ukraine's long-range weaponry
a priority
this video released by the russian
defense ministry claims to show strikes
on the us weapons in ukraine that's a
sign that moscow sees the additional
firepower as strategic the pentagon said
russian claims that the systems were
destroyed were false
but despite initial success in slowing
down russia's offensive ukraine says it
needs more support to reclaim lost
territory in the next stages of the war
the biden administration which has sent
9.8 billion dollars in military aid to
ukraine amid the war has considered
sending more advanced systems western
allies have
been um
very kind of excited and satisfied by
the way in which the ukrainians have
used these
these tools quite effectively instead of
providing more of
the systems
they may provide more ammunition and
longer age munition and then there's
there's also been talk recently about
providing the ukrainians with
fighter jets
that addition could bolster ukraine's
air fleet which is eclipsed by russia's
in terms of numbers of aircraft
and more modern fighter jets would allow
ukraine to strike behind russian lines
and to provide air cover to its troops
but so far the u.s has resisted giving
ukrainian forces weapons that could be
seen as escalating the conflict that's
because of concerns from some u.s
officials that the equipment could be
used to strike targets within russia and
even if more advanced tools are provided
to keeve ukrainian operators will still
need to be trained to use them
in the meantime ukraine isn't expected
to regain territory using haimars alone
instead military analysts say they will
continue to play an important supporting
role
so as the war grinds on ukraine is going
to be in need of more of pretty much
everything whether it's tanks or
arms ammunitions
but it seems like the highmars will
continue to be a really important
part of that mix
and they've enabled the ukrainians to
make a statement of how effective they
can be